* Brouhaha, plusieurs voix *
Tout ce bruit, à chaque instant, même lorsque tout est éteint, tout est coupé,
ça ne s'arrête pas.
Et c'est même dans la tête, ça jaillit. Comment j'en suis arrivé là ?
A quoi ressemblera demain ? Est-ce que je coucherai avec Kim Kardashian, si je le pouvais?
Tellement de questions...
Et tout ce bruit... Et tout ce bruit...
* Tonalité de téléphone *
- Allô maman ?
- Oui, Cyrus ? Ca va ?
- Ca va et toi ? Je te dérange pas ?
- Non, non, ça va, ça va !
- Ouais, je t'appelais parce que j'ai décidé de... de partir.
- De partir euh... Quand ?
- Euh, là, je pars à la fin du mois, là !
- Tu connais ta destination ?
- Ouais, je vais au Népal, à Katmandou !
* Claquement de porte *
J'avais envie de partir loin, et seul. M'échapper.
Et croyez moi ou non, j'ai choisi Katmandou parce que le nom sonnait bien.
Katman-d'où tu viens ? Katman-d'où tu fais ça, tu t'es cru chez toi ou quoi ?
Katman-doux et soyeux... Bon, j'arrête...
Mais pour être très honnête, c'est peut-être pas le meilleur endroit pour échapper au bruit.
Non, c'est pas du tout le bon endroit.
En fait, "loin", c'est pas ce qu'il faut. Ce qu'il faut c'est "loin des autres" !
Atteindre le silence.
J'ai rencontré Clément, un français, qui m'a expliqué rapidement les bien faits de la méditation.
Euh non, c'est pas lui.
Voilà, c'est lui !
- La méditation, en ce concentrant sur notre souffle, puis sur nos sensations,
- ça permet de renforcer notre faculté d'attention et sortir de notre tendance naturelle
- à l'attachement ou à l'aversion.
Se détacher de ses désirs et de ses aversions...
Oui, c'est peut-être ça dont j'ai besoin ! Et c'est ce que j'ai fait !
Je me suis un peu éloigné de la ville, et pendant une dizaine de jours,
c'était mon mentor, mon souffle, et moi !
La méditation devint mon bruit, et je vivais au rythme de ma respiration !
* Inspiration * Vraiment au rythme...
* Expiration *
Et une fois que c'était fini, j'ai pu commencer à découvrir le Népal...
Et c'était fou !
- Je fais le malin, vite fait, à...
- à me filmer en marchant, et tout...
- mais en vrai euh...
- c'est quand même un peu galère, hein !
- Je ne vous le cache pas !
Et durant tout ce temps, je me suis observé.
J'ai observé mes sensations, mes désirs, mes aversions,
à essayer d'être conscient, plus que je ne le suis d'habitude !
Je me suis installé chez une famille, qui produit son propre café !
Alors j'aime pas du tout le café, mais ils étaient supers gentils !
Et j'étais complètement calme !
Complètement serein.
Et cette sérénité, ce calme, ça a laissé de la place à de l'amour.
L'amour non intéressé. L'amour d'une mère pour ses enfants.
L'amour sans rien en retour !
Le bonheur est possible seul, oui,
mais lorsque l'on touche du doigt ce bonheur imperturbable, qui nous remplit,
et qu'on brise notre égo, alors nous ne faisons qu'un avec le reste.
"Je" n'existe plus, "l'autre", c'est moi.
On oublie les chemins que l'on emprunte, mais on n'oublie pas les gens.
Surtout quand ils ont failli nous coûter un drône.
Et c'est le chemin que nous a montré, plus de 2000 ans plus tôt, le grand Siddhartha Gautama,
qui après des années de pratiques, devint le Bouddha.
Une fois éveillé, il a passé sa vie à essayer de transmettre ce savoir aux autres.
Plein de gratitude, tourné vers le monde, puisque le "soi" n'existe plus !
Alors qu'on soit bien d'accord, je ne vous dis pas que je suis heureux à jamais.
J'en suis très loin. Et c'est une lutte, une lutte de tous les jours, ça demande un effort.
Mais être autant de jours dans le silence, à m'observer,
ça m'a permis de comprendre en tout cas, à quoi pouvait ressembler ce bonheur là.
J'aurais l'occasion de vous en reparler, ne vous en faîtes pas !
Le Népal compte 30 millions d'habitants,
de nombreuses religions, avec des hindous comme des bouddhistes,
qui prient les uns à côté des autres.
Une situation politique extrêmement compliquée, qui a débouché sur un gouvernement qui oublie sa population,
pourtant dans le besoin, depuis le séisme de 2015,
et qui connaît de très gros problèmes d'infrastructures.
Et malgré ces problèmes, c'est un pays extrêmement accueillant,
et méditation ou non, j'y devais une grande part de ma sérénité !
Je voulais les aider !
Bijay m'a expliqué l'un des problèmes qu'il rencontrait le plus souvent dans sa vie de tous les jours.
Et ça n'a rien avoir avec le fait de ne pas avoir assez de temps pour mater toutes les séries qu'il y a sur Netflix.
En me rappelant de la tête des panneaux électriques, ça ne m'a pas surpris !
Et je ne vous parle pas des panneaux solaires, qu'on peut voir un peu partout,
même dans des zones assez rurales.
D'ailleurs ça a fait écho à un message que mon père m'a envoyé quelques jours plus tôt,
un jeune népalais, qui essayait de faire bouger les choses.
Du coup, ça devenait assez évident.
- Ouais mec !
- Salut !
- Bye !
- Ciao !
- On est parti !
Madindra a 25 ans.
Il a élaboré un appareil, qu'il a baptisé "The Nepal's light", qui alimente aujourd'hui 500 foyers,
et qui a une autonomie de 12 heures. 12 heures de lumière !
12 heures pour pouvoir charger ses outils de communication,
et rester en contact avec le monde qui vous entoure !
Le mec a aussi construit un drône, dans le plus grand des calmes.
- Merci !
- Au revoir !
- Au revoir, merci beaucoup ! Merci !
Son produit coûte très peu cher, moins de 20 dollars.
Mais malgré ce prix très faible, Madindra a besoin d'un coup de pouce.
Il a lancé une campagne IndieGoGo pour pouvoir fabriquer et distribuer 5.000 panneaux.
Et c'est de ça dont je veux vous parler. C'est là qu'est mon utilité !
Je peux faire le pont, entre Madindra, et vous !
Alors je vous met un lien, vers sa campagne IndieGoGo.
Allez jeter un oeil !
Et si vous voulez l'aider, n'hésitez pas !
Le Népal m'a fait un bien fou ! J'espère lui faire un peu de bien aussi...
Et maintenant, avant de rentrer, j'étais prêt pour un peu de bruit.
Venez !
Je voulais remercier chaleureusement tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur Tipee,
sans quoi je n'aurais pas franchement eu l'idée de faire une vidéo au Népal,
en tout cas avec des moyens comme le drône, par exemple.
Vous avez fait la différence, et pour ça je ne vous dirais jamais assez "merci !".
Merci de soutenir mon contenu.
Un grand merci aussi à Clément Touchard, pour la musique.
On aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans le Making-Of, qui sort la semaine prochaine.
Soyez sûr de me suivre sur Facebook, Twitter et Snapchat, pour ne pas rater les infos.
Et d'ailleurs sur Snapchat, vous avez été nombreux à me suivre, en direct au Népal,
et c'était un plaisir de partager les moments que je pouvais avec vous.
Soyez heureux !
Toutes et tous.
Je vous aime.
On se voit la semaine prochaine.
Namaste
- Quel est ton nom ?
- Et ton frère ?
- Soeur, c'est ma soeur.
- Ah, ta soeur... désolé !